[Music]
leave your entries in the subreddit
clothes types huge announcement watch
this oh wow it's so big isn't it Wow
oh it's go bigger wow it's such a big
dam buried oh it can't go bigger can't
it what this is impossible it's
beautiful I told you tambourine will
come back stronger than ever
20% muscle increased tambourine for
every million subscriber we get
tambourine grows from now on what are we
at 105
come on 106 can we do it let's get into
the wife leave your memes on the reddit
nineteen-year-old
donation you peepee sewed up the why
before this video begins a word from our
sponsor tapped items to skit was super
fun I've been playing it whenever I have
spare time somewhere it's free I highly
recommend it check it out just tap away
shut up I'm tapping tap times 2 is an
epic Idol RPG with over 20 million
downloads
it's like Diablo except the enemies come
to you I warn you though once you start
you can't stop
I'm serious I can't stop help me I don't
know why it's so satisfying I guess how
it has such sophisticated RPG system
where you get different armors different
weapons different pets then question
mark as well as on a skill and talent
points to upgrade your epic sword
masters and you can unlock other people
that help you this game will keep you
busy basically forever because if you
think you can't get any further there
you can prestige all this so when I
recommend this because you will not
watch my videos anyone there are
holidays avenge tournament twice a week
where you compete with other players to
get the highest level same developer
just released their latest brick breaker
RPG a legendary brick breaking game
check it out as well
link in the description thank you tap
Titus 2 is it legit cool game III mean
it check it out
you'll Upland fix the broken clock bus
who fixes a clock like this it's called
improving it
who improves the tambourine like this I
do you're welcome musicians I can hear
myself really hello hello who's talking
hello are you a wedding son yes this
millionaire on the internet said I have
a huge dick hell yes hell yeah that's my
boy it took me a hundred hours to do
this
what and we got sides that's probably
one of the better ones and like how the
quality of these is exponential just
better and better every day what's gonna
happen next
Marvel level of animation I bet I'm
gonna make you mind the reality is the
tambourine might tell loves to
tambourine I seen all this meme saying
that mics it doesn't like tambourine she
loves that number right there how can
anyone not like it congratulations Chris
I will hit the tambourine three times in
your honor
very nice that's amazing Congrats Four
Horsemen of getting free advertising
through a memes meme I said where sonic
would be the other week wasn't that bad
I expect they worse sorry no I was all
right better than the last of us check
out the live streams guys of me playing
the likes of us it's great everyone
loves it tears running to Italy to sing
for a girl you met online that's quite
enough how did you get the live footage
of what happened how did you get it I
thought I deleted it from the Internet
it's working
yes yes hahaha we are converting them
it's working our subliminal messages
have been the interests are working guys
more interest please oh wait no what is
this
No Oh oh my god kind of kiss so you
think I'm bad I'm just I'm a bad person
okay yeah oh my god don't know how to
rate this I don't know how to rate this
cuz it hurt to my crack oh my lord
hey furry devices I have a favor to ask
or maybe higher I'll check your themes
I'll reach out for a free future project
ksi reacts to PD PI subreddit oh this
doesn't seem like the most
representative posts but okay sure when
in case I go bro I guess it's time I
guess it's trying to rebuke site reddit
let's get it I will be honest if it's
garbage
it's garbage if it's good is good let's
go
two three hours the hell am i watching
that poor lion well case I may not have
Domino's videos but he had sick at it's
not gonna like can barely tell that this
is seat yeah what we see what case I see
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn let's say this is JD you're
supposed to shave his head come on [ __ ]
do it
shave your head already don't do it
seriously it's not worth it don't do it
don't try it Anakin it doesn't matter
don't get bullied by your audience
alright got some good laughs out of the
case I subreddit epic reddit there's
supporting epic reddit or schoo
subscribe to ksi subreddit yeah yeah
thanks for checking it out appreciate it
man is it me or is Felix Kjellberg kind
of high I don't get it
what is this has anyone noticed Felix
cameras focus on the mic instead of his
face
god dammit is it still doing that I
don't think so
probably oh my god it's another ayane
trick they keep getting better they keep
getting better
Wow Wow we're going eh Wow oh my god
another one holy [ __ ] dude
[Music]
[Applause]
that's huge beefy I like that house it
seriously impressive when you effing put
a lot of ethics wears so f inside has to
F into a lot of ethnic editing holy F
that's the evilest thing I can ever
imagine don't work site I got you know
more swore in this video
sadly break slightly break from brush
sound effect Mario Kart is video game
designed to realistically simulate what
driving is like it it totally none me
I'm diving in dude I don't understand
this because I haven't watched part
three yet I'm watching mob psycho right
now if you have to ask it's very funny I
like it a lot
for the coca Mel and baby to have blonde
hair while his parents have brown hair
you must have the recessive gene or as
shown in punnett square lower case C it
is possible right
yes oh you got me Coco melon small PP
conferred ow ow ow let's remind pills
that he is common in pics links and
Felix's mythic we what this is a
disgrace wherever you are
Felix Kjellberg I will find you and I
will shove this tambourine somewhere you
will not like like it oh my god Holmes
let's hope edgar seizes the council of
tambourine has spoken
ed guy he's not here right now sorry
I'll show him later he was gonna be
thrilled
trust me surprise Edgar was inside the
tambourine I'm kidding I would have been
epic with me surprise I merged my dog
with the tambourine
Felix trying to get my Alexa to buy hair
gel Alexa buy hair gel Alex set by hair
gel me wearing headphones he's stupid
goddamnit I'll get you one day alexsei
users Alexa delete yourself Oh minecraft
player want one thing Cave update no yes
come on Mojang stop slacking up come on
Mojang I need a reason to get back into
Minecraft please
ace is all I ask pity pie should bring
back pew news because regular news is
depressing I told you cut Pappa Gloria
recovering from treadmill incident I
guess you could say anything is a waste
of time like I'm just looking at memes
that doesn't give any deeper insight or
anything like that it's just an
entertainment for the moment and in some
ways you can say the same about Kunis
but I just generally find that the stuff
that gets reported on penis are so
unimportant that people get way too
worked up over and I don't want to keep
spreading that on the internet you
should not be wasting your life on the
those kind of topics because they're not
important they cycle through all the
time and people get upset over things
that aren't important and I'm tired of
it I said it twice just to make my point
double clear Felix just finished episode
68 of Reddit reviews so for the next
episode he should review are nice
because that would be nice hell yeah
oh my god alright alright alright that's
happening that's happening for sure
this is why I'm glad I have the little
why because otherwise I would have just
missed out on the most legendary moment
of my life come on who married Mars
episode 9 PewDiePie hell yeah hell yeah
got you you sneaky snake thought you
could sneaky snake your way in there you
snake 19 years and what you got there
Felix at Disney pigs a smoothie Edgar
has definitely not merged with a
submarine as a submarine ax to avoid
Edgar nude pics to get laid Jesus Christ
I keep seeing these stuff stop please
please Alexa and her husband such a cute
couple
oh god vice yeah why I can't look at
this at least I look cute but this is
all your meme wasn't lost in you it just
wasn't funny damn Big Ed speaking facts
like it or not god damn what a savage J
oh my god
okay hey
haha
yeah
[Music]
you have no chance melon man no chance
Hey
[Music]
god damn dan that's impressive
massive PP shoutout to all mean um milky
god damn that's so cool oh man
Jojo is the best aren't you just glad
you're living the same time let miss
Jojo
think about that yes it's working
another one another would no no no don't
leave no oh god damn a god [ __ ] oh god
damn it why I gotta look so cute come on
in ancient times for is used to wear
skulls of their prey or enemy to
symbolize their victory so kids where's
the water metal and helmet it wouldn't
mean cats are always happening for now I
have my tambourine crown as its table
[Music]
sign out here ready for me I'm back baby
thank you yeah good names I'd give me
well done
you live up to the honor of the
PewDiePie yeah oh the most wholesome
part of this live stream right here oh
yeah I know way I know way
damn that's so realistic without oh no
please it's just joke okay cringe don't
copy strike just cuz I call you a top
man you can name your chair floor and
still the floor again that's how we're
doing it gamers that's how it is
I'm flora gang sitting on the house is
still on my hand seriously they're
younglings peers upload members only
because remember the uploaded has not
made it video available in your country
no it should be available in a couple
days it's just annoying how the system
works it is what it is people fighting
over PS 5 and Xbox who has them more
weird than me me games like that
definite state to an Albany my homemade
PC
oh I swore sorry sighs it's gotta be a
good air ventilation at least once I'm
waiting for the Everson guy have to feel
like sir the third temporary too late
mites yet and it's gonna keep going baby
beautiful you're my new bed back in my
new child tambourine is like father to
me nothing's gonna stop you from growing
bigger and bigger I took a picture on
PDP and Photoshop feel expect guys stop
god damn it softest damn we got another
one
Hey
I love the details damn oh my god
massive peepee so cool rare photo fede
pine Felix Kjellberg well we do look
similar sometimes sometimes I agree
cocoa melon piri pie yeah that's a good
child right there well done Felix else
we'll make a dude strike on Cocoa melons
video at 500k legs but it still hasn't
made a peep peep video with markiplier
PP video coming so soon guys
so honestly I it trust me on this one
kids when he sees a meme he doesn't
understand I diagnosed you with small
peepee small peepee this meme gets as
well congratulations you just played
yourself my 9 year old but really twelve
year old sister made this frame by frame
using clip a clip on their tablet ah
that's so sweet
well definitely use this that's
impressive
[Laughter]
no I was just looking at some cuts yeah
that was a weird meme Revere not gonna
lie thank you sorry for finally using
idea of putting the controversy on this
screen it's genius
that's how we got away with three third
cursed comet videos so far I'm glad you
guys like them they're fun every once in
a while why does feel the Shelby I have
a friend that looks exactly like Putin -
oh my god in contain yos know who is
just copy-cat
I'm sick of it oh it's just booty by
Phillies game bag see that's pretty good
Doofenshmirtz am i right no alright rare
insults does anyone else think this
looks like PewDiePie on drugs I mean
that's not the most flattering light so
fair enough
come on don't be rude guys he's a
beautiful man he looks like PewDiePie
not Felix Kjellberg
whoa oh my god I got too many intros
this is great keep them coming
Oh use all of them his legs are actually
Edgar's back no no they will not figure
me out okay Armitage dead buddy attached
to my clothes clothes but they add gir
one it's the closest one we have so far
I'll say that much at least monsters in
Minecraft if three places don't hit me
on Swedish understandable have a great
day man I have a great day come on
scythe follows coca melons sigh you're
done you're done I knew it
traitor traitor scum and follow right
now sigh and apologize I expected a four
filled page letter of apology
[Music]
when floor gang merch came in the same
day that period ended floor gang no no
no no we still floor gang out here oh oh
oh
cherish floor remember get it get it
it's all good it's all good
okay assign that throw gang after all
what's small PP you wouldn't get it also
you get it what I don't get it to the
Chen murky Chen
Jackie good name alright gamers that's
it for this week hope you enjoyed this
episode if you did smash like become a
member right now you get access to
private discs or you get access to my
only famous account Members Only check I
joined the community have fun it's epic
so you guys send the live streams for
your life's ringing last of us right now
it's pretty it's a game it's a game all
right
brofist see you guys
do you haven't played super simulator on
the beach good pack your bags and sit
down no one wants to see your face max
tan lines
anyway download tuber simulator for the
perfect beach body